please don't judge me I have to put
everything into context all right so
it's my sophomore year in college I was
dating a girl and we wanted to do
something special for each other for
Valentine's Day I think that most people
think of like the bubbly champagne and
chocolates because this was college of
course I'm broke I mean I'm on the orals
and noodles budget that's a kind of find
creative ways to make this special so I
created this ambiance know what I'm
talking about the ambiance my friend and
next-door neighbor had a whole bunch of
roses that he put on his bed and he was
doing it for his girl and I said just
give me three three rose petals boom
boom boom on my pillow it's not about
the quantity it's the quality fellas all
right chocolate Sarah because I knew I
was gonna get a little bit freaky I had
this cheap bottle of champagne
I made my gonna get you some playlist of
strong black singers and I knew it would
get her there I didn't have enough money
for cologne at the time so I'll spray
some Glade and air Jasmine berry if you
frequent or fresh water I would prefer
and I just made sure i dim the lights
just enough where she could see me do my
little dance that I had planned to do
for it that I didn't get a chance to
when my girlfriend at the time came over
she's wearing nothing but a trench coat
and cowboy boots and I was like first of
all where did you get these cowboy boots
from I thought it was weird but as she
took off her trench coat
she revealed to me that she didn't have
much on it was a to top and kind of like
boy shorts and it said gym ears girl
across from me I'm Jimmy by the way come
on I brought into the room and she was
really impressed really impressed by the
three rose petals so we're getting into
it very nice still pg-13 I had some oil
and I was rubbing it on him
so I'm doing my thing I had not get to
do a boom boom boom and I'm thinking all
right well I hope somebody has a knife
wound because you're interrupting my
flow so I'll open the door and I see my
friend bleep but right behind her
leans over and it's my ex-girlfriend and
she's like do you have a lighter the
first thing that I thought of was I
don't smoke crack and I closed the door
but you know I don't smoke crack I'm
just letting you guys know as my auntie
Whitney said crack is wack crack is
cheap so now I kicked everybody out I'd
get back to my thing she asked who was
it I said you knows the wind drop I
don't worry about it let's just get back
into the love thing that we have at the
moment not a chocolate syrup has been
applied all right twenty minutes go by
and I have a boom boom boom again this
is interruption number two at this point
and I don't well who got to catch these
hands now I go to the door and it's
blank who happens to be my roommate side
piece or guma depending on where you're
from and she's hysterical like I can't
find them I don't know where he is
he said that we would go out for
Valentine's Day but he's not answering
his phone by the way my roommate is
literally in the next room with his
girlfriend at the time doing the same
exact thing I'm doing but way more
successful we're literally like three
feet away from each other so it is no
way he's not gonna get caught at this
moment I said I haven't seen him I try
to reach out to him and I'll let you
know as soon as I hear from him she says
okay well I'm gonna wait right here on
the couch that's a UH do what you want
I'm going back to my room I text my my
brother and I said hey man you know you
gu ma is literally on the couch just
waiting for you he goes tell I'm in the
hospital and I go hey you know he's in
the hospital and she popped up like oh
my gosh what happened and literally the
first thing I thought about was he has
the gout um and she didn't know what
that meant you might not know what gout
is hell I don't really know what gout is
but I know it has something to do with
sodium and your feet so I was like yeah
that that Glau did it flares up and it
just attacks everything she was like oh
my god should I go there I said no don't
go there you should just like go back to
your room like just believe she said no
I want to be the first person that he
sees when he walks through that door
and I said at this point you can do
whatever you want
despite everything that happened I'm
still ready I'm still
motivated so I go back in the room I
left his goomar on the couch so I close
to home at this point there's no longer
pg-13 this is a rated R movie and then I
hear boom boom boom and I said it better
be Jesus coming to Punk me or tell me
that the rapture is coming so I open the
door and I recognize my friend she's
hysterically crying I'm like what
happened oh my god
my boyfriend broke up with me I just
don't know how I'm gonna make it and she
moves me out the way and runs straight
to my girlfriend who she also knows who
is still covered in chocolate and naked
by the way this is not I promise you not
what the Playboy channel described this
situation would be I listen to this for
35 minutes and then I say hey blank
alright
don't you see I'm in my boxes you see
this robe you have to go it's 3 o'clock
in the morning at this time she's like
I'm just gonna sit out here with blank
guma and and we're gonna watch a movie
alright do what you want this is so
weird so after that situation I'll go
back in the room
my girlfriend actor tom is like I'll be
honest with you it didn't start out like
this but this has been the best
Valentine's Day - I've ahead I looked it
a little weird maybe that's why we broke
up but I looked a little weird I said I
don't I don't think that okay if you had
a good time I had a good time I looked
at her and I was like I hope you don't
want me to perform because it's not
gonna go down tonight and she said I
know gave me a pat on the shoulder and
then we cuddled up and we watched Mary
with children reruns at 3 o'clock in the
morning needless to say that was the
most memorable Valentine's Day
experience that I've ever had if you're
playing in Valentine's Day make sure
that there's a strong sturdy lock on
your door padlocked if you can a whole
bunch of locks and if you hear some
knocking don't answer it it's okay now
if you happen to have a Valentine's Day
story as crazy as mine leave them in the
comments right now